quand j'étais petit garçon je repassais
mais le son en chantant
et bien des années plus tard je chassais
mais si tu es noir en chantant
c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant de
parler du mauvais temps en chantant et
c'est tellement plus mignon de se faire
traiter de con en chansons
la vie c'est plus marrant c'est moi
désespérant en chantant la première
fille de ma vie dans la rue gelé suivi
en 100 ans
quand elle s'est déshabillée j'ai joué
le vieil habitué en chantant
j'étais si content de moi que j'ai fait
l'amour 10 fois en 120
mais je ne peux pas m'expliquer au matin
elle mais qui paie en santé l'amour
c'est plus marrant c'est moi
les airs
on s'entend d'où les armes
en galère
à la pêche ou à la gueule
ensemble
la fleur au bout du fusil la victoire se
gagne aussi en chantant
on ne parla jéhovah à jupiter à bouddha
qu'en chantant
quelles que soient nos opinions ont fait
sa révolution en chansons
le monde est plus marrant
dr
chantant
puisqu'il faut mourir
que ce soit côté jardin ensemble
ce matin on a de la peine
que mes enfants la soutient
en chantant
quand j'irai revoir
kima tend les bras
on s'entend
j'aimerais sur la terre
mais bon comme un menteur
enchantée
à
chantons
quand j'étais petit garçon je repassais
mais le son
en chantant
et bien des années plus tard je chassais
mais il est noir en chantant
c'est beaucoup moins inquiétant de
parler du mauvais temps en chantant
c'est tellement plus mignon de se faire
traiter de cours en chansons
et bien voilà le spectacle est terminé